3 2 1
action this movie it was like a breath
of fresh air with a story that's outside
the bounds of R doll's original material
I thought it was magical I really wanted
this movie to be able to sit as a
companion piece to the original movie I
know how much it means to people because
it means a lot to me too Paul's doing a
really exciting reinvention of Willie's
origin stories in this story Willie is
going to have to find help from other
people he can't do it on his own he gets
help from the House Gang we recognize
that he could be brought into the fold
we see the effect of that teamwork come
into
play so you're the funny little man
who's been following me I will have you
know that I am a perfectly respectable
size for an OAA I don't think it would
be a Willy Wonka film unless there were
umpl lumpers it felt like they had to be
there we would try to think of somebody
who could be very Superior and
judgmental and very funny at the same
time and Hugh Grant was the only person
to play it that's my last job
I said good
day in this story Willie is ambitious
enough wiely enough to come up with a
plan to not only help the Wash House
Gang but also realize his dreams as a
chocolate
here